Georgia Meloni devrait devenir
présidente du conseil des ministres ce
serait ce sera ce serait la première
femme à occuper ce poste dans l'histoire
du pays Norbert dit Evangelista
le scénario était écrit dans les
sondages les Italiens l'ont confirmé
dans les urnes Fratelli la formation
d'extrême droite de Georgia Meloni
devient le premier parti d'Italie
[Applaudissements]
les Italiens pour ces élections ont
envoyé un message clair en faveur d'un
gouvernement de droite
dirigé par Fratelli d'Italia
si nous sommes appelés à gouverner cette
nation nous le ferons pour tout le
peuple italien
avec plus de 26% des voix la formation
crée il y a tout juste 10 ans place la
coalition des droites et extreme droite
transalpine en tête des élections
législatives et sénatoriales elle
devance et de loin le mouvement 5
étoiles et le Parti démocrate qui ne
sont pas parvenus à faire barrage à la
vague d'extrême droite qui s'abat sur
l'Italie et sur l'Europe
italienne les Italiens et les Italiens
ont choisi c'était un choix clair et net
ils ont choisi la droite l'Italie aura
un gouvernement de droite la tendance
apparue il y a deux semaines en Suède se
confirme également en Italie aujourd'hui
est un triste jour pour l'Italie et pour
l'Europe des jours difficiles nous
attendent
des jours difficiles face à un véritable
séisme en Italie un pays fondateur de
l'Europe pour la première fois depuis
1945 les Italiens sont sur le point de
faire marcher sur Rome un parti post
fasciste
Fratelli d'Italia a réalisé une
véritable percée depuis les dernières
élections législatives le parti avait
obtenu moins de 5% des voies en 2018 il
a cette foire récolté plus du quart des
suffrages des voies en partie siphonnés
à la Ligue la formation d'extrême droite
de l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
Mateo Salvini empêtré dans des
embrogliopolitiques qui n'ont pas plu
aux Italiens
aujourd'hui nous commentons un chiffre
dont je ne suis pas satisfait 9% ce
n'est pas ce pourquoi j'ai travaillé
mais avec 9% nous sommes dans un
gouvernement de centre droit dans lequel
nous serons des protagonistes
sans changement sans bouleversement en
mettant seulement les choses à faire au
centre des intérêts
du matin j'ai échangé des messages au
téléphone avec Georgia que je félicite
y compris
elle a bien fait nous allons travailler
ensemble longtemps et bien
ce qui promet d'être long pour Georgia
Meloni désormais et bien de convaincre
ses alliés de lui céder la place de chef
du gouvernement une revendication
légitime qui devrait prendre comme c'est
souvent le cas en Italie quelques bonnes
semaines et je vous présente tout de
suite mes invités Marc Lazar bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur
d'histoire et de sociologie politique à
Sciences Po et président de la School of
gouvernement de l'université Luis à Rome
Pascal Joana bonsoir bienvenue
directrice générale de la Fondation
Schuman Stefano monte Fiori bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes le
correspondre à Paris du journal italien
de la Serra pardon pour mon accent et
Mathieu croissanto évidemment est resté
à mes côtés peut-être votre réaction
globale on va dire ça comme ça les
sondages annoncés Marc Lazare cette
victoire de geor la mélodie de ses
alliés c'est pas une surprise est-ce que
vous voudriez quand même que c'est un
choc
évidemment c'était la chronique d'une
victoire annoncée pour différentes
raisons les sondages mais aussi le mode
de scrutin on y reviendra peut-être oui
c'est un choc on est en 2022 ont
commémore le centenaire de la marche
Rome c'est la première fois qu'une femme
va accéder à la présence du conseil et
cette femme a été fasciste elle ne renie
absolument pas mais l'adolescence c'est
ça
dans le fascisme elle a été longtemps
fasciste elle est dans une processus
long compliquée de sortie du fascisme
tout en gardant un certain nombre
d'éléments de continuité et donc elle va
accéder au pouvoir dans un pays dont la
Constitution est antifasciste oui un
choc effectivement Pascal Johanna
comment vous l'analysez vous cette
victoire jameloni alors moi c'est moi la
victoire de Giorgia Meloni que je note
que c'est l'effondrement de des autres
parties parce que que ce soit le parti
de haut démocratico la Lega ou même le
mouvement
ils sont tous en déclin d'au moins la
moitié ou presque par rapport à 2018
donc ça veut bien dire que c'est une
victoire qui est liée au fait que les
autres parties se sont tous écroulés ou
non pas été capables de s'entendre aussi
il y a pas eu la coalition de gauche
comme elle a réussi à faire cette
coalition de droite alors qui nous
semble complètement
des années-lumière en France parce que
ça rassemblerait le rassemblement
national de Salvini les Fratellis
italiens dont on n'a pas encore et puis
porta Italia les républicains qui sont
au PPE donc c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement étonnant il y a pas eu
l'équivalent à gauche sauf ce que je me
trompe et tous les autres partis ce sont
écroulés et on voit en effet des chutes
vous montez des photos de de Salvini il
est à 8 il a été vite
qui avait fait le gouvernement en 2018
complètement un peu aussi une alliance
un peu hétéroclite qui n'a pas duré donc
il faudra voir si en effet cette
alliance parce que voilà maintenant que
elle est devant est-ce qu'elle va être
présidente du conseil et qu'elle va être
la ligne du programme avec Perlo scan on
va évidemment Stefano monté Fiori il
faut peut-être expliquer ce qui va se
passer là maintenant effectivement donc
c'est le président de la République qui
nomme les ministres mais déjà la
présidente du conseil des ministres et
c'est important c'est déjà la première
démarche dans d'autres occasions c'était
pardon peut-il nommer quelqu'un d'autre
que Georgia Meloni bah théoriquement oui
dans la pratique vu le résultat non
parce que ça serait complètement
inexplicable d'un point de démocratique
la victoire des Georges Mélanie clair et
donc c'est sur c'est presque sûr sauf en
prévu mais c'est vraiment ça ça serait
un choc alors là vraiment que président
materiel dans le non
mais non président du conseil c'est
d'ailleurs c'est le jeu de la démocratie
c'est logique est-ce qu'il a quand même
un peu de pouvoir le président de la
République sur ces
[Musique]
la position des groupes parlementaires
ça peut paraître très étrange mais il y
a un certain nombre d'élus qui peuvent
changer ok l'orientation non mais ne le
prenez pas sous la forme non je cherche
à comprendre mais je vais vous expliquer
c'est que par exemple des élus dans le
val d'AOS dans la région un statut
spécial sont des tout petits partis qui
doivent se s'affilier à des groupes
s'ils veulent exister donc voilà et puis
parfois il y a des transfuges il peut y
avoir par exemple des députés de la
Ligue qui se disent la Ligue c'est
terminé vaut mieux que j'aille du côté
de Fratelli d'Italie à tout de suite
donc voilà c'est donc sur le charme
mélodie va peut-être agrégé d'autres
soutien
encore le président de la République va
engager les les consultations de tous
les partis politiques alors il y a tout
un rituel ça prend deux jours en général
au palais du coryza et puis le président
de la République donne ce qu'on appelle
Linka Rico c'est à dire on pourrait
traduire par la mission qui sera donnée
sans doute à ma mélodie pour lui
demander si elle a une majorité
parlementaire et ensuite si tout ça
fonctionne madame mélodie monte comme on
dit parce que c'est sur la colline de
Corinne dans ce magnifique palais
présidentiel et elle de son gouvernement
et là c'est l'article 92 de la
Constitution et l'article 92 de la
Constitution Stéphane on le rappelait le
président de la République nomme sur
proposition du ministre et on sait très
bien il peut mettre un veto il l'a fait
en 2018 et il l'a fait parce que le
gouvernement de Giuseppe comté 1 proposé
un ministre de l'Économie des Finances
très connu en Italie très réputé mais
qui était pour la sortie de l'euro et il
a dit il en est pas question parce que
ça remettra en cause les engagements
internationaux de l'Italie donc il y a
une crise pendant quelques jours mais il
a gagné et il y a plusieurs ministères
clés pour Monsieur matarella le
ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère
des Colonies finances le ministère des
Affaires étrangères et le ministère des
Affaires européennes et donc il va y
avoir une discussion entre madame Meloni
elle a un avantage c'est qu'elle a près
de 26% elle a largement gagné ce scrutin
même même dans le dans le jeu de pouvoir
avec ses alliés évidemment c'est très
important je vous propose une première
réaction celle d'une ancienne députée
italienne du Parti démocrate Mickey la
Marzano plus que choqué elle dit elle
dit avoir peur pour son pays c'était ce
matin sur France Inter elle est très
très à droite bien plus à droite
d'ailleurs que Marine Le Pen donc plus
que choqué je suis effondrée parce que
j'ai peur j'ai peur pour l'Italie je
perds pour l'Europe j'ai peur pour les
femmes j'ai peur pour
les étrangers j'ai peur pour les
homosexuels tout ce qu'elle a dit il va
le faire et si tu es une femme xénophobe
homophobe dangereuse alors je vais vous
donner la parole aux uns aux autres pour
essayer de la situer effectivement
politiquement de Georgia Meloni vous
vous dites quoi
j'ai remarque comme une différence que
mon avis est intéressante c'est-à-dire
en Italie on appelle la coalition qui a
gagné des centres droits de centre alors
que vu d'ici on dit
l'extrême droite du gouvernement le plus
extrême droite depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale
de cette coalition qui sont plutôt à
minimale à droite de la droite
d'accord et disons que la l'addiction
centre droite résiste parce qu'il y a
encore force italienne dellucon qui a
pour la caution centriste et européiste
de la coalition mais déjà c'est
intéressant de voir que il y a des gens
courants sortent de normalisation de la
de la situation et même dans les mots
pour caractériser
alors qu'effectivement on peut pas c'est
pas de Chirac à l'italienne c'est autre
chose c'est voilà c'est une droite
différente dure et elle a juste titre on
peut l'appeler d'extrême droite ça c'est
déjà révélateur d'une certaine façon
qu'est-ce que vous retenez vous de
peut-être du programme et donc de ce que
Georgia Meloni si elle obtient voilà
suffisamment de marge de manœuvre comme
ça semble se mettre en place qu'est-ce
qu'elle va prioritairement vouloir
changer dans son pays d'après vous
est-ce qu'on dit pendant la campagne et
puis ce qu'on fera après est en charge
et on passe donc de d'une candidate à
faire des podiums des tribuns et donc on
sait très bien que elle mettra peut-être
pas en application tout ce qu'elle a dit
il y a des exemples récents de l'autre
côté du Channel par exemple ou madame
Trust a dit des choses et puis elle fait
le contraire de ce qu'elle dit à la
campagne parce que maintenant il est
investi et que les responsable et donc
ça change un peu la un peu la donne donc
je crois que Madame Meloni a en effet
vous la connaissez mieux que moi dit des
choses pendant la campagne qui sont qui
font dresser les jeux sur les têtes mais
elle a aussi peut-être dit des choses
qui sont à entendre elle n'est pas
anti-européenne primaire comme les
Marines Le Pen et je rappelle que Marine
Le Pen a des alliés au Parlement
européen avec Matteo Salvini siège dans
le même groupe les Fratelli d'Italiens
ne siègent pas avec Marine Le Pen et
Salvini sont chez les conservateurs
c'est c'est vous me dites que ils sont
tous les deux avec Marine Le Pen dans le
même groupe George et à Mélanie n'est
pas avec Marine Le Pen au Parlement
européen elles sont avec conservateur
polonais ou avec les Démocrates suédois
oui il y a déjà dans la communication
est troublante c'est l'extrême droite
sur l'Europe elle a quand même dit
qu'elle était pas antihelle elle n'est
pas contre l'Ukraine alors contrairement
à ce qu'avini qui dit qu'il est pour le
pour la Russie etc donc il y a déjà un
antagonisme là-dessus elle veut plus
elle veut pas sortir de l'euro comme
Marine Le Pen voulait sortir de l'euro
alors bien entendu tout ça est à prendre
avec des pincettes mais il faut voir ce
qui sera fait avant de prendre des
mesures pour dire elle est le diable en
personne peut-être en effet sur le côté
européen et le côté économique je
rappelle quand même que l'Italie et le
pays qui grâce au plan de relance
européen un ex generation a le plus de
fonds européens c'est fond on commence à
être versés sous Mario Draghi parce
qu'il est arrivé en février 2021 si vous
voulez bien sûr la partie européenne
donc je vous interrompre là-dessus parce
qu'on va vraiment y consacrer du temps
mais Marc Lazar là je voudrais plutôt
qu'on soit sur peut-être les valeurs les
les réformes sociétales là on entendait
cette ancienne députée italienne de
centre gauche voilà le décrit une femme
homophobe elle dit attention aux droits
des droits des femmes notamment une des
positions un peu ambigu sur l'avortement
évidemment
l'islam est mis ennemi juré de mélodie
désigné enfin qu'est-ce qu'elle va
qu'est-ce qu'elle va appliquer ce qu'est
le pourquoi elle a été élu sur ces
thèmes là c'est un des grands thèmes de
Georgia Meloni depuis quelques temps et
notamment à l'occasion de cette campagne
sur ces thèmes sociétaux
incontestablement que que vous avez
rappelé et on pourrait en rajouter
d'autres en gros elle est pour la
défense de la famille traditionnelle
pour les valeurs chrétiennes et de ce
point de vue là elle est très proche
d'orman et donc c'est une autre
conception de l'Europe c'est l'idée que
l'Europe a commis une erreur
fondamentale parce qu'elle ne prend pas
assez en considération le danger de
l'islam qui par ailleurs n'est que si
j'ose dire la troisième religion en
Italie puisque la seconde et la religion
orthodoxe et ça elle joue beaucoup
là-dessus donc qu'est-ce qu'elle va
faire je sais pas je ne elle a dit
qu'elle remettrait pas en cause par
exemple la loi sur la loi 194 qui
autorise déjà sur des conditions sont
très restrictives l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse mais enfin c'est
elle qui avait signé en 2019 la première
signataire d'un document par son parti à
Rome pour demander que les fœtus des
femmes qui ont avorté soit enterrés dans
un carré particulier de tous les
cimetières Romains avec le nom de la mer
y compris si la mère refuse de faire
cela donc ça donne un peu l'état
d'esprit de cette femme et elle en
rajoutera d'autres et puis à la question
de l'immigration et des migrants sur
lesquels elle est très en pointe et
comme je crois comme vous Pascal que
elle ne pourra pas faire grand-chose sur
les questions économiques qu'on va y
revenir donc elle risque d'en rajouter
encore plus sur les autres sujets il y a
aussi l'homophobie sur le alors
attention est-ce que est-ce que vous
employez ce terme-là moi je l'emploierai
oui elle a une disons qu'elle n'a aucune
sympathie et encore moins d'empathie
avec les couples homosexuels bon ça je
pense que voilà elle par exemple sur les
questions de l'IVG elle va favoriser les
organisations les associations provient
et on le sait déjà ils sont partis
dirige la région des Marches et dans la
région des ils ont pris des décisions
qui justement restreignent la
possibilité d'interrompre volontairement
une grossesse pour les femmes et
favorise l'action des sociétés des
associations
de droit des femmes les régions en
Italie ont beaucoup plus de pouvoir que
chez nous et que ça dépend un petit peu
beaucoup des régions chacun ayant à une
politique un peu à part la durée de la
possibilité d'interrompre la grossesse
n'est pas la même inhumilatéralement et
donc en effet c'est une compétence qui
est quand même très régionale donc en
effet il y a des régions peut-être où ça
sera dramatiquement réduit je sais pas
comment ça va se passer celle que
contrôle le mouvement Fratelli italien
et ce qu'elle ne contrôle pas
elle s'en est pris quand même ce qu'elle
appelle le lobby LGBT et qu'elle répète
dans ce meeting voilà les sur les
questions que la théorie du genre il y a
une identité sexuelle selon elle il y a
pas à changer de façon un lundi de de
gens enfin bref elle est quand même
assez marquée un argument très fort
aussi en faveur de la natalité et ça ça
pourrait marquer dans un pays
caractérisé par un soldat naturel
négatif elle insiste beaucoup là-dessus
elle dit qu'il faut faire et sans doute
là elle prendra des mesures
d'accroître encore les incitations les
plus faibles de l'Union européenne on va
évoquer ce que cette union des droits ou
de droite et d'extrême droite peut
provoquer ici en France mais je voudrais
juste vous pouvez dire totalement de
curieux sur Silvio Berlusconi 86 ans
dans trois jours je crois qu'est-ce qui
vient faire là
chercher un peu de pouvoir encore à cet
âge-là le maillon faible de la collision
parce que quand même il arrive pas même
pas 9% et il a donné aussi des signes
des faiblesses personnelles
dans les derniers jours et elle s'est
lancé dans un tout un discours à propos
des Poutine qui le revendiquent encore
comme son ami en disant que l'impection
russe voulait simplement amener des gens
bien acquis donc là franchement on a
aussi pensé que peut-être qu'elle avait
vraiment perdu un peu le contrôle de la
situation de la gestion des supposons
garants de des deux autres formations
exactement il se pose comme l'élément
centriste comme on disait tout à l'heure
de la de la coalition et mais les
résultats quand même est très faible et
il a déjà vécu cette montée au pouvoir
en 1994 il était dans la main coalition
si si l'on veut sauf que là
exactement
le rapport de force j'étais complètement
à l'opposé et c'était lui qui était
la puissance de la coalition donc il
pouvait endosser plus facilement ce rôle
des des celui qui est démocratise un peu
les extrêmes là il est il sert un peu
comme la caution démocratique de la
condition mais c'est plus difficile sa
position alors l'Union des droites
évidemment il y a beaucoup de réactions
enthousiaste on va dire de ce côté de de
l'échiquier politique ici en France par
exemple Marion maréchal sur Twitter
alors elle s'affiche tout sourire aux
côtés de Georgia de la mélonie et avec
ce texte elle a su tenir bon à la su
faire l'union bravo pour cette victoire
historique bonne nouvelle pour la
défense de notre civilisation
#modies Italie Mathieu vous analysez
justement la réaction alors du leader de
du parti de Mario maréchal reconquête
Éric Zemmour c'est le premier homme
politique en France à publier un
communiqué Salvan la victoire du Georgia
mélodie c'est donc
Eric Zemmour qui a salué évidemment la
victoire de l'Union des droites on sait
que c'est sa ligne écrit qui a raconté
une petite histoire il y a 4 ans Georgia
Meloni recueillait 4% des suffrages ce
soir elle est en passe de diriger
l'Italie malgré leur échec en 2018
madame Meloni et son jeune parti n'ont
jamais rien lâché voilà ça vous fait
penser évidemment à quelque chose et
d'ailleurs il conclut comme ça qu'est-ce
que ça montre comment ne pas regarder
cette victoire comme la preuve que oui
arrivée au pouvoir c'est possible en
fait dans notre débord la vie moi je
pense qu'il y a plus de proximité entre
le mouvement reconquête d'Éric Zemmour
et Fratelli d'Italia contre le
rassemblement national et Fratelli
d'Italia on l'a dit c'est vrai que
Marine Le Pen est et et le mouvement
Fratellis Italiens ne siège pas dans le
même groupe à Bruxelles au-delà de ça
les deux femmes se connaissent mais ne
se fréquentent pas la dernière fois
qu'elles sont vus c'était en 2016 elles
ont pas prévu de se voir tout de suite
genre jamais mélodie conseillère que
Marine Le Pen est plutôt populiste alors
que elle est une vraie de ce qu'on voit
de l'extérieur et vous le corrigerez
conservatrice
identitaire vous souvenez de ce slogan
qu'elle acclamé en 2019 et qu'on a revu
en boucle passer sur toutes les chaînes
de télé je suis femme je suis mère je
suis italienne je suis chrétienne il y a
donc une affirmation
identitaire très forte qu'on retrouve à
mon avis davantage chez Eric Zemmour
ensuite sur les questions de société on
le voit bien elle est extrêmement
conservatrice aujourd'hui personne au
rassemblement national ne m’entonnerait
ce qu'elle dit sur
l'IVG sur la famille sur le rôle des
femmes qui est de rester plutôt quand
même à la maison en tout cas participer
à la croissance démographique du pays
donc c'est son slogan je crois mais vous
me congrez ou ça devise c'est Dieu
famille patrie pas quelque chose que
qu'on entendrait aujourd'hui
rassemblement national
en revanche Cherry Zemmour oui il y a
une affirmation identitaire oui il y a
une mise en avant de selon lui les
valeurs dites chrétiennes de la France
oui il y a une répartition des rôles
entre la femme et la et l'homme qui
correspond à sa vision un peu
nostalgique des années 50 ou l'homme
travaillait ou la femme reste à la
maison donc il y a des passerelles puis
il y a des passerelles aussi
personnelles j'ai envie de dire puisque
Marion maréchal que vous avez cité et
quand même l'épouse devient Sochaux
voilà qui était un ancien de la Ligue
mais qui est passé à Fratelli d'Italia
donc il y a beaucoup plus de proximité
et on voit bien que ça fait rêver Éric
Zemmour cela dit bémol Éric Zemmour
s'imaginerait bien
accomplir cette passe de 2 il faut
expliquer qu'en France c'est très
compliqué d'abord parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de différence elle a commencé
par le système le mode de scrutin ne
favorise pas à nous en France il y a un
système majoritaire de Tours là-bas on
est dans un système proportionnel en
France à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
encore jamais eu de majorité
sociologique sur des thèses ultra
conservatrices ultra identitaire je ne
dis pas qu'elle n'existe pas dans le
pays mais plus d'un Français sur deux
sur des tests comme ça ça ne sait pas
pour l'instant vérifier mais cette
question de l'Union évidemment elle
agite aussi le parti elle est en pleine
campagne pour l'élection de son nouveau
président une première réaction sur
cette question stratégique s'allier ou
non à l'extrême droite c'est celle
d'Aurélien Pradier sur Twitter il refuse
cette idée voilà ce que dit Aurélien
Pradier en regardant l'Italie certains
se disent que le seul avenir de la
droite française est de devenir soufre
des agités c'est la fascination morbide
de ce qui chez nous n'y croient plus ils
ont perdu l'exigence du gaullisme moi
j'y crois tout rebâtir ne m'effraie pas
en revanche le député européen
François-Xavier Bellamy lui il franchit
allègrement le Rubicon l'écoute
c'est évidemment le signe comme comme ce
qui s'est passé en Suède au fond que il
est temps d'écouter enfin ce que disent
les citoyens européens les citoyens des
pays européens moi je suis fasciné ce
matin je vais vous dire sur le trajet en
écoutant la radio on avait l'impression
que un coup d'état fasciste était en
train d'arriver en Italie et quand on
écoute
certains certains récits des médias la
vérité c'est que c'est une coalition qui
inclut des parties dans certains
d'ailleurs comme la Liga a été en
coalition avec les socialistes jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et ça n'avait choqué
personne cette coalition c'est vrai
aujourd'hui elle est le signe elle est
le signal que les Italiens demandent
qu'on se préoccupe enfin des problèmes
auxquels ils font face et notamment de
la question migratoire
Marc Lazare le on l'a déjà fait un débat
sur ce thème ici sur ce plateau le point
commun de ces extrêmes droites
européennes même si évidemment elles
sont elles sont diverses c'est gommer
certaines de leurs aspérités pour les
rendre acceptables pour une peau
coalition est-ce que vous l'analysez
comme ça oui bien sûr non bien
évidemment un mouvement de fondation des
diabolisation tout en maintenant une
identité
pour ce qui concerne madame Meloni bien
sûr elle ne se dit plus fascisme en même
temps il dit sa partie en passé c'est
pas la peine de revenir là-dessus ce qui
moi ce que j'appelle une stratégie
d'évitement on endresse pas le bilan
d'envoyer parfois même des messagers
elle a fait une déclaration très
intéressante pour ceux qui connaissent
bien c'est elle a dit je pense à tous
ceux qui ne sont plus là et ça veut dire
quoi ça donc moi j'entends ça bien
alors elle pourrait penser à son père il
a quitter le foyer familial très petit
non tout le monde l'a interprété dans le
dans le noyau dur les admirantes alors
il faut
dirigeant du MSI c'est très clair c'est
des petits signaux comme ça subliminaux
qui rentrent dans la la dans dans les
traditionnalistes mais oui c'est
important cela dit moi je pense que
peut-être que j'ai un désaccord avec
vous sur Mathieu c'est que je pense que
vous avez raison le mode de scrutin
différent mais je pense que le débat va
surgir obligatoirement à droite et
d'ailleurs il est présent dans les
républicains on le voit il y a d'un côté
les républicains qui disent c'est pas
possible on vient de l'entendre et puis
il y a ceux ericsiotti alors on va
Wauquiez qui se disent on peut faire une
alliance à la Mitterrand avec dans les
années du programme communiquant les
voix aura rassemblement national
je pense que le débat va être là et au
sein du Rassemblement National Marine Le
Pen jusqu'ici a toujours refusé là
encore redit récemment pas question mais
je pense que ça va venir comme débat
d'ailleurs il y a un quotidien
j'apprécie puisque on m'interroge
souvent le Figaro un certain nombre de
ces chroniqueurs depuis quelques temps
ainsi sur cette idée pourquoi pas et
puis il y a
la Une du Figaro pardon je vous donne la
parole je sais plus c'était samedi je
crois c'est c'était l'Union des droites
il y avait pas le mot extrême droite à
la Une c'est c'est pas totalement je me
permets de rajouter juste un tout petit
point c'est que 38 à 40 % des électeurs
de droite aujourd'hui disent qu'il faut
c'est fini il faut faire l'alliance donc
je ne dis pas que ça va être facile à
régler mais je pense que le débat est là
alors je suis d'accord mais ce qu'il y a
c'est qu'il y a quand on interroge les
électeurs de droite une partie est déjà
passé chez Emmanuel Macron donc il reste
c'est quand même une droite moins
nombreuses et par ailleurs le
rassemblement national n'a jamais voulu
aujourd'hui de l'Union des droites
jusqu'à présent pour la simple raison
qu'elle veut remplacer la droite et que
je pense que ce ce verrou là n'est pas
prêt pour l'instant de CD parce que tant
qu'elle est en position de force elle
s'est qualifié deux fois de suite au
second tour avec son présidentielle elle
dit j'ai rien à faire avec ces gens-là
je vais les remplacer et d'ailleurs elle
a pas tout à fait en plus les mêmes
analyses ou les mêmes politiques sur le
plan de vue économique
intellectuels les commentateurs les
journalistes alors cette question de
l'Union des droits de vous l'avez évoqué
et j'ai proposé à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre parce qu'elle se pose
évidemment
euh dans plusieurs pays en Europe et ce
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau style non
l'Italie déjà elle faisait figure de
précurseur dans les années 90 on est au
début des on est au début 1994 la
démocratie chrétienne est au pouvoir
depuis plusieurs décennies surgit alors
dans le paysage politique à toute
vitesse un homme des médias audacieux
populaire son nom Silvio Berlusconi il
crée sa formation de droite force à
Italia et nous une alliance avec deux
formations d'extrême droite la Ligue du
Nord et surtout alliance nationale un
parti issue du MSI le mouvement social
italien le MSI c'est une formation Neo
fasciste crée en 46 après l'interdiction
du parti de Mussolini et c'est
d'ailleurs cette organisation le MSI que
Georgia Meloni rejoint dans son
adolescence à noter qu'en 94 vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure c'est la droite de
Berlusconi qui arrive devant l'extrême
droite aux élections législatives
aujourd'hui évidemment c'est l'inverse
et récemment on a assisté à d'autres
rapprochements entre la droite ailleurs
en Europe oui direction l’autriche ou en
2017 les conservateurs menés par
Sébastian course remporte largement les
élections législatives deux mois après
le scrutin un accord de coalition est
officialisé avec l'extrême droite du FPO
arriver où il y a SPO arrivait 3e lors
de ces élections un accord qui réserve
le poste de vis chancelier à Hans
Christiane président du FPO et surtout
proche de la mouvance néonazi c'était
dans sa jeunesse alors des néonazis
historiques qui se normalisent en
quelque sorte on en trouve aussi
aujourd'hui en Suède les Suédois se
rendaient aux ordin il y a deux semaines
pour des élections législatives là-bas
c'est le parti d'extrême droite qui est
arrivé en tête à droite ce qui veut dire
que la droite va devoir bien apprendre à
composer avec elle pour gouverner le
parti d'extrême droite s'appelle la
balle et démocrate de Suède son premier
dirigeant a fait ses classes dans un
mouvement néo-nazi mais en 17 ans son
actuel leader et bien fait passer le
parti d'extrême droite du statut de
paria à formation incontournable au
Parlement écouter le
il s'est passé tant de choses ces 12
dernières années aujourd'hui nous sommes
un grand parti je suis tellement fier et
tellement heureux du chemin que nous
avons parcouru ensemble
la Suède qui prendra la présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne en janvier
prochain il faudra regarder comment
évidemment l'Europe ça commode de ces
unions entre droite et extrêmement
droite merci beaucoup Steve alors
effectivement on va parler de du centre
de gravité de quoi vous
parlezable de faire des apartés comme ça
donc on va parler de la question du
centre de gravité de l'Europe est-ce
qu'il est en train de basculer vous
voulez dire un mot sur l'Autriche
allez-y non non sur le son de gravité de
l'Europe je suis tout à fait d'accord
pour parler votre présentateur
je suis seul qui en 99 a fait déjà une
alliance avec le FPE qui parle qui était
et en effet Jacques Chirac et d'autres
avaient dit c'est pas possible etc et on
avait eu à ce moment-là atlash au niveau
de l'Union européenne et donc c'était la
première tentative d'un parti vraiment
d'extrême droite alors le centre de
gravité de l'Europe qu'est-ce que ça
change finalement qu'on est en Italie en
Suède des gouvernements qui alors
ensuite ça va être un peu plus compliqué
mais une sorte de coalition droite
segment pour l'instant faudrait pas
croire que l'Union européenne est
débordée par Anne-Marie le train ou je
ne sais pas quoi les pays qui sont avec
des dirigeants conservateurs populistes
etc sont au nombre de deux ou un moment
on se parle la Pologne et la Hongrie qui
ne sont d'ailleurs pas dans les mêmes
groupes politiques et qui ne s'entendent
pas je rappellerai simplement que Orban
et pro russe alors que les Polonais ne
sont pas du tout d'accord donc voyez
donc c'est pas une famille il y a pas
une famille homogène une grande famille
qui va peser ensemble alors sur l'autre
bord politique à l'extrême gauche la
Grèce avec Syriza et donc en effet de
cyprès et un clash qui est très vite
intervenu entre siriksa et son ministre
de l'Économie pas aux FAQ en traenant
qui était pour le pragmatisme mais un
qui était pour le jusqu'au-boutisme et
on a aujourd'hui deux pays voulaient le
dire la Suède est l'Italie qui ont en
effet voté récemment les cas sont un peu
différenciés en effet ici dans le même
groupe les conservateurs avec les
Polonais il semblerait que les
Démocrates suédois donc le parti
d'extrême droite
au sein du gouvernement
il en sera certainement une cheville ou
tutélaire
il ne sera pas au gouvernement alors
qu'il est le premier parti arrivé à
droite je rappelle que c'est les
sociaux-démocrates qui sont arrivés le
premier parti mais comme ils ont fait
une parution Pascal même s'il y a pas de
stratégie comme une jante en ça mais il
y a quand même une vision de l'Europe
qui est pas celle de de des valeurs de
des pays fondateurs donc il y a des il y
a des contradictions on le voit avec la
Pologne
qui ça va jusqu'à des des subventions
qui sont qui sont interrompus le
gouvernement qui sont et encore au
gouvernement leur Suède n'est pas
terminé mais c'est le modéré le modéré
il est au centre droit c'est pas du tout
l'extrême droite
Christophe Sun donc il y a en effet
peut-être mais s'accommoder de l'Europe
alors d'abord mélodie elle a pas dit des
choses contrairement je rappelle
deuxième chose que l'Europe des plus
celle de 1999 ou etc on a changé un
petit peu de on a traité de Lisbonne etc
il y a aujourd'hui des outils bien
entendu les gouvernements font ce qu'ils
veulent mais il y a des règles communes
à respecter et on a vu que la Pologne et
la Hongrie pour des raisons différentes
n'avaient pas respecté un certain nombre
de règles qu'ils ont été sanctionnés et
ce que madame vanderline a dit là
pendant la campagne c'est que si jamais
l'Italie de Meloni Salvini Berlusconi
venez à être en effet très limite il y
aurait des moyens de la faire revenir
dans le droit chemin tout simplement
parce qu'il y a en effet des règles et
qu'il y a ce plan de relance et
aujourd'hui l'apologne est revenue dans
le droit chemin sa réforme de la justice
elle l'a remise en question parce
qu'elle n'avait pas les fonds européens
Orban après avoir crié sur tous les
toits qu'il était contre est en train de
faire passer toutes les réformes que
l'Union européenne a demandé 17 pour
pouvoir bénéficier des fonds européens
et c'est ce soudage je vais expliquer
tout à l'heure l'Italie est le premier
bénéficiaire du plan de relance européen
il y a déjà eu deux versements sur Mario
Draghi mais il reste encore beaucoup
d'argent et ça m'étonnerait que Madame
lenoli aille vraiment pas titiller au
chatouiller la Commission européenne sur
cette question comme vous l'avez dit et
je pense que c'est plus sur les
questions sociétales que ça risque
d'être et si on et là pour le coup
l'Europe est fait parce qu'elle n'a pas
de politique migratoire européenne
finalement on en revient l'argent quoi
oui on revient à la jambe sous l'erreur
je suis d'accord je pense pas que
mélonie se fera des choses
éclatantes pour sortir de l'Europe ça
c'est une discussion mais pardon c'est
quand même attendu par une grande partie
de son électorale ça
je pense pas mais quand même la donnée
change la dynamique change en Europe
c'est-à-dire ok on a eu pendant quelques
mois mon situation un peu un moment de
race pour les pro-européens parce qu'il
y avait draguer en Italie Macron à Paris
chaude en Allemagne il y a on a eu la
sensation qu'il y avait quand même unité
des valeurs d'action et des volontés
politiques on ne peut pas imaginer
maintenant un voyage en train Meloni
Macron Scholtz pour aller voir
là c'est même si maintenant ne fera pas
des des n'ira pas jusqu'à la rupture je
pense que les équilibre en Europe ont
déjà changé des ce matin mais Marc Lazar
il y a une phrase qu'elle a prononcé la
fête est finie c'est à propos de
l'Europe dans un meeting à Milan mais là
on a essayé de comprendre ce qu'elle
voulait dire mais je pense que c'est
relié à tout ce qu'elle raconte sur
l'identité nationale en gros elle dit
maintenant les Français les Allemands
savent défendre leurs intérêts et nous
les Italiens non donc c'est une
accusation de tous les gouvernements
précédents et avec moi ça va changer et
avec moi ça va changer parce que je vais
défendre les intérêts nationaux et c'est
là où il va y avoir tout un jeu d'après
moi un peu compliqué encore une fois ça
va dépendre des ministres désigner
attention on a commencé on a commencé
par là
ça va dépendre mais en même temps elle
va essayer de faire valoir ce qu'elle
appelle les intérêts nationaux donc il
va y avoir beaucoup de rhétorique
beaucoup de grandes déclarations
sans doute avec Varsovie et Budapest
malgré le désaccord sur la Russie un jeu
de la part de Georgia Meloni pour
montrer à la France et l'Allemagne
qu'elle voudra peut-être rééquilibrer
avec sa proximité idé et politique très
fin vraiment l'homme qu'elle admire le
plus en Europe c'est Victor Hormann elle
a un lien très fort d'ailleurs Victor
urban s'est fait un malin plaisir dès
hier soir de féliciter Giorgia Meloni et
de présenter les photos où on le voit
lui avec Matteo Salvini Silvio
Berlusconi et Giorgia Belloni les bras
dans les enfin on la sait en quelque
sorte donc elle va quand même essayer de
peser pour essayer de changer un peu ces
rapports et dans le programme en 15
points du centre droit puisqu'on
l'appelle comme ça moi je l'appelle de
plus en plus droite centre d'ailleurs
parce que c'est la droite qui domine et
bien il est marqué que il y a une
veulent une Europe plus politique
bureaucratique alors qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire elle elle a une conception
confédérale elle est sur la position
polonaise et hongroise une Europe ou le
droit national l'emporte sur le droit
européen et c'est pas par hasard que
frère d'Italie et la Ligue ont voté
contre la résolution du Parlement
européen qui condamne l'évolution en
démocrate ça veut dire qu'on peut
s'attendre à un bras de fer un peu
similaire à celui qu'on a eu avec la
Pologne par exemple je pense qu'on
pourrait avoir des moments de tension
importante avec la limite indiqué c'est
qu'elle ne peut pas tirer trop sur la
corde parce qu'il y a le plan de relance
et qui a 55 objectifs qui doivent être
atteints d'ici décembre 2022 il y a 55
objectifs et là à peine arrivé elle doit
faire la loi de finance
pas facile une dernière action justement
elle aussi elle est en train de préparer
la loi de finance c'est la première
ministre française et Elizabeth borne
sur l'élection de Georgia Meloni ce que
dit la présidente de la commission c'est
que en Europe on est on porte un certain
nombre de valeurs et que bien évidemment
on sera attentif et la présidente de la
commission à ce que ces valeurs sur les
droits de l'homme sur le respect des
autres notamment le respect du droit à
l'avortement par exemple soit respecté
par tous et ils avaient de bande qui
évidemment vous l'avez compris faisait
référence à une déclaration d'Ursula
vanderlione je voudrais terminer il nous
reste de 2 minutes 30 Pascal Joana sur
la relation franco-italienne là parce
que Emmanuel Macron était quand même
assez souvent critiqué par Georgia
Meloni pendant sa campagne ce que vous
disiez quoi
c'est pas son nom européen favori quoi
on se souvient que l'histoire avait dit
qu'il ne savait pas si Emmanuel Macron
était un ami
politique la France et l'Italie s'ouvre
le contrôle de Marc Lazare et de
Monsieur ont quand même renforcé leur
lien bilatéraux avec ce traité du
querinal qui n'est pas vieux donc je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils en feront les
Italiens maintenant ça c'est autre chose
mais il y a quand même des garde-fous où
elle pourra pas non plus faire sauter et
renverser la table donc elle peut en
effet elle est dans des directions sur
ces questions sociétales ou sur ces
questions migratoires ou en effet là
madame la Première ministre a dit des
valeurs c'est surtout sur l'état de
droit c'est surtout ça qu'on est sur
laquelle on peut avoir des choses donc
il y avait la réforme de la justice il y
avait un certain nombre de réformes sur
la liberté des médias etc donc c'était
les choses qu'on avait de reprocher à où
les universités en Hongrie donc à Orban
ou à la justice en après sur les pays
bon le droit l'avortement on a on a des
règles mais qui sont pas il y a des pays
qui ne tolèrent toujours en l'occurrence
et d'autres pays donc il y a pas de
règles européennes donc c'est c'est plus
du on essaye de faire en sorte que mais
c'est pas une règle européenne strict au
sens Stéphane c'est peut-être pas en
France qu'elle fera son premier voyage
officiel
je pense pas mais je vous ai dit que ça
sort des surprises ça serait intéressant
non mais ça serait intéressant aussi de
voir quel sera l'attitude du
gouvernement français bien sûr qui se
trouve dans une situation très très
inconfortable parce que d'un côté bien
bien évidemment il faut garder la
relation privilégie jusqu'à maintenant
privilégié avec avec l'Italie quand même
tous les liens historiques qu'on connaît
très bien de l'autre côté
légitimer est complètement un
gouvernement avec une leader d'extrême
droite ça va poser problème pour la
politique intérieure française parce
qu'après ça ça va devenir difficile des
diaboliser Marine Le Pen en autre
candidat d'extrême droite si on a des
excellents relations avec la chef du
gouvernement italien il nous reste une
minute marque Lazare on peut pas faire
ce débat sans donner un chiffre quand
même c'est l'abstention 36% d'abstention
et c'est beaucoup plus dans certains
dans certaines villes du Sud
cette défiance alors elle est pas
seulement italienne mais cette défiance
elle est majeure quoi oui elle est
majeure et je pense que ça explique le
discours qui a fait Georgia Meloni dans
la nuit en disant qu'elle s'adressait à
tous les Italiens et d'abord parce
qu'encore une fois c'est 45 % elle sait
qu'il y a 55 % des Italiens qui n'ont
pas voté pour la coalition droite
vraiment il y a encore une fois ils
étaient divisés et puis il y a ce taux
d'abstention très important et c'est ce
qu'elle veut essayer de régler parce
qu'elle sait pas simplement l'alternance
elle veut véritablement faire ou tenter
de faire une alternative pour régler les
questions de la défiance politique et
régler mécontentement social d'ailleurs
avec un mix de proposition de
libéralisme économique et de protection
sociale dont on comprend pas exactement
quelle va être la tenue quand elle sera
présidente de conseils merci beaucoup à
tous c'était passionnant merci pour ce
débat je vous dis à bientôt dans ce sens
public votre prochain rendez-vous
politique sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
la matinale évidemment
qui reçoit manuellement le bon part le
député LFI des Bouches-du-Rhône ce sera
à 8h demain matin bonne soirée